[Music]
thank you
Christmas
to have some music let's have some music
[Music]
on the first day of Christmas my true
love gave to me SG one on The Daily
World on the second day of Christmas my
true love gave to me
two Samantha Carters unless she won on
an alien world
the third day of Christmas my true love
gave to me
to meet you can Deeds to some of the cat
is underneath
on the fourth day of Christmas my Jewel
of gave to me four great bases three
silk in these two Samantha goddesses
[Music]
on the fifth day of Christmas my true
love gave to me
I've started Rings
four great Racers three tilkey needs two
Samantha Carters and this G one on an
alien world with trees on Sixth Day of
Christmas who gave to me
sixth time Daniel died five years
four great Racers three tilting these
Deuce among the counters unless she was
on the seventh day of Christmas my true
love gave to me seven Chevrons locked
six times Daniel died
[Music]
four great races three two okay these
two circumfer characters
[Music]
on the eighth day of Christmas
the episode citizen Joe
six times
four great racers
because
they're here for Christmas episodes
[Music]
I gave me
four great Racers three Two Kitties
[Music]
ten amazing seasons and on the other
side fbo2 season an episode
look six thumbs down you'll die
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
well that good did you like that did you
like that we can get rid of that now
[Music]